hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over my top nine
aggressive chess defenses that i like to
use i know many of you are aggressive
players like i am and so today we're
going to be looking at the openings that
i use as black if i want to be extremely
aggressive i'll be curious in the
comments below what your favorite
aggressive chess defense is and see if
it lines up with what i have in my list
so without further ado let's go ahead
and hop into my top nine list
coming in at number nine we have the
dragon variation in the sicilian defense
the sicilian being one of the sharpest
lines in all of chess for black after e4
c5 here and then knight to f3
pawn to d6 you usually see an exchange
in the center of the board here then
after knight to f6 attacking the pawn
knight to c3 defending that pawn black
plays pawn to g6 and this opening is
chaotic it doesn't matter if white plays
the main line to bishop to e3 looking
for a quick development to castle on the
queen side or if they play the hyper
aggressive pond f4 the leaven fish
attack either way
it's going to be madness but white
usually looks to castle on the queen
side black castle on the king side and
it just becomes a race of throwing
everything you have at your opponent's
king
and it gets wild there's a lot of other
variations you can look at the
accelerated drag and the
hyper-accelerated dragon
those are just some shortcuts but they
are not as aggressive as the dragon
variation so if you're looking for
something extremely aggressive in the
sicilian i definitely recommend the
dragon coming in at number eight we have
the faulkner counter gambit which is a
direct attack on the king's gambit
e4 e5 and then pawn to f4 this is the
king's game it is my favorite line as
white extremely aggressive from white
and black says i can play just as
aggressive pawn here to d5 pushing both
of the central pawns
opening up for this light square bishop
to get involved also preparing to take
here on e4 which would attack this f3
square which normally this knight is
coming here to f3
this is an extremely aggressive line for
black these games typically don't last
more than 30 moves because there's so
much chaos there's so many traps that
both sides can fall into so this is
definitely something if you are playing
as white you better be prepared because
black is ready for a fight so that's why
it is number eight on our list
coming in at number seven is the nemzo
indian defense after pawn two d4 then f6
white really tries to control the center
with the queen side pawns here after e6
if white plays knight to c3 then black
responds with bishop here 2b4 pinning
down this knight and many times there's
an exchange with the bishop in the
knight white's left with double pawns
here on the c file many players as white
will try to whatever they can to avoid
these lines because there's so many
aggressive lines for black and also it
scores favorably from black's
perspective so you may even see instead
of knight to c3 things like knight to f3
anything they can do to make sure that
they do not allow their opponent to play
the nemzo indian defense
coming in at number six we have the
icelandic game it already starts from a
pretty aggressive line from black and
that is the scandinavian offense with e4
d5 but after the pawn takes black avoids
the most common line if queen takes here
knight to c3 kicking the queen back and
black says we're going to go ahead and
give you that material let's play knight
to f6 you can defend it with pawn here
to c4 but then we're going to play pawn
e6 opening up for both of our bishops
now get involved into the game black has
this
queen here on d8 semi-open file that he
can start getting involved into the game
the knight on f6 has already developed
and black has a lot of room to attack
the opponent if you have not tried this
one he's definitely gonna want to check
out the video i did on the icelandic
gambit it is a fun one for sure
i am curious if you guys like this video
if you wouldn't mind hitting the like
button that definitely helps out the
channel a lot i think a lot of people
are going to like this video and i am
just curious to see what other people
think are their most aggressive chess
defenses that they they like to play if
you wouldn't mind let me know in the
comments below
what your favorite chess defense is
coming in at number five we have the
schliemann gambit which derives from the
rye lopez fairly common opening in chess
e4 e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and after
bishop to b5 many times white is in the
driver's seat the slimy game it says not
so fast my friend we are going to play
pawn to f5
we're gonna give up material here on f5
to control the center of the board
have no fear if you look and say the
king side is not well protected black
usually ends up castling on the queen
side and this is pure chaos you also
have a lot of opportunity to play this
defense because many times white really
likes to play the right lopez they feel
like it's safe they feel like they're in
a good spot and then you hit them with
the slim and gamut and they just have no
idea what to do
coming in at number four is one of my
favorite defenses and that is the
latvian gambit people just do not expect
you to play it and that is e4
e5
knight f3 and then pawn two f5
immediately striking the center of the
board here i think this may just come
from the fact that i like to play a lot
of kings gambit so i'm just extremely
comfortable always pushing my king side
pawn here on the f file up to control
the center of the board
get a lot of other material involved and
try to put a lot of pressure on my
opponent but the latvian gambit is a fun
one pure chaos if you haven't tried it
definitely check out the video i did on
that one it is a ton of fun but it is
chaos
coming in at number three we have the
russo game but one of the most common
openings in chess is the italian game
with e45 and that f3 knight c6 and then
bishop here to c4
and black says okay you're trying to be
pretty aggressive here we are going to
be just as aggressive and that is
playing pawn to
f5 putting a lot of pressure on the
central square here and a lot of players
do not know how to respond so black many
times can have the upper hand here so if
you haven't checked this one out i
definitely recommend it is an extremely
aggressive line from black
coming in at number two we have the
staffer gambit fan favorite and that
derives from the pet drive defense after
e4 e5 knight f3 knight to f6 if you
watched much chess on youtube you've
probably seen a lot of videos on the
stafford gambit and it is a ton of fun
to play after the knight takes here on
e5 the main line is d6 forcing the
knight to come back here to f3
but that's not as fun as the stafford
gambit and that is knight to
c6 and then after the knight takes then
black plays pawn takes c6 you can see
everything is open for black
both of the bishops are ready to get
into action the queen here is ready to
get into the action and black already
has a developed piece here on f6
extremely aggressive line from black and
a ton of fun to play
curious in the comments below if the
stafford gambit ranks extremely high on
your list of defenses to play as black
because i
personally love this opening
coming in at number one we have the
traxler counter attack starts out with
e4
e5 and then f3 and knight c6 bishop here
to c4 the italian game knights f6 and
then white plays the fried liver attack
you've probably come across this or
maybe even played this yourself with
knight to
g5 and then you have the traxler counter
attack i really like playing this in
person as well because then you can play
and look at your opponent let them know
that you're the captain now you're in
the driver's seat you don't care if they
play the fried liver attack you have
just as strong attack as they do and
that is bishop here to c5 so yeah you
can attack my f7 square i don't care
because the pain is coming i'm attacking
your f2 square and we can just duke it
out till the end of the game
extremely aggressive line from black and
that is why it is number one on my list
thank you guys so much for watching the
video hopefully you enjoyed my top nine
aggressive chess defenses if there was a
defense that i left out
please let me know in the comments below
also curious if you agree with my
assessment on what i think the best ones
are to play
thank you guys so much for watching the
video and i will see you guys next time